hello everybody envision well from John
Burroughs I think Marilyn Katherine
Kenneth cinder and for no medical PRC
and today I'm going to talk about using
grommets to for molecular or physical
learning so it's a one-minute version of
this talking gives you a really rare
ability so it's a network that operates
on the pots of illogical space and
molecules and it propagates and arrogate
information fishing pollen and atoms and
so forth and we show that it is capable
of predicting remarkable through Ataman
for bone attributes such as the energy
of the monaco the charge of the abdomen
Evanson an otter off the bones and we
also apply this model to generate some
very interesting things related to the
for example we use that we are studying
how to use this word a lot of the
General Conference of my goals as well
as responding San Marcos themselves and
in addition we are also exploring the
ideas of using this kind of model to
directly parameterize a force field so
what is growth and what is graph net so
in the terminology of ground learning
the graph is a set of sets so it is a
set of the sets of edges vertices and
universal attributes or the sort of
master nodes so here we model Proteus
and monocles as the dentists are of
course the chemical bonding about
proteins and molecules versus are the
atoms and the universe - Therese is
something that you put as the property
of the entire model worth the entire
posting something like driver likeness
ology uh Felicity finding free energy
and so forth could be all this in the
master node so we bought model the
voting's and Bob posed as some directed
known image and Rob that reduces and
unlabeled graphs the the death we need
to model this data under acted the graph
because there is always a mirror
symmetry plan in all of the chemistry
kind of chemistry bond you have your
cronies and Marcus with there are a few
exceptions but you couldn't afford to
have a graph where the nose or that some
those where something attributes are
some engines are not attributed
it's just a design choice and we used
our label graph because if you use the
label graph they you need to choose the
set of labels you put on each note which
breaks in black variants so gruffness is
a set of six functions that operates on
a topological space of the graph the
three functions on the left are update
functions and esprit functions on the
right are aggregate functions the update
functions for expertises and universal
knows updates as ugly the corresponding
thank you
sorry update the Carphone entities based
the attributes of that entity at
previous time step this is a time
dependent motto as well as its
surroundings so the aggregate functions
will just aggregate information from a
set of entities to a object with the
same division allottee of each element
in that set so for example a typical
choices of aggregated functions include
sum or average or mass so duty of craft
knives instead of gruff your place at
double row is both the problem you are
trying to solve
as pasta space on which you're solving
this problem so that's just to give a
little bit us tration of how the each of
these function works before digging into
their codes so let's say you have a
little social graph of three notes here
it's just a bunch of friends hanging out
in the bar
something like picture of the Sahara
like that so that's just a reiteration
over to graph notation we brought this
the set of sets it's the center of the
sense of versus the seven Angeles was a
universal global attribute so the first
thing to do when you have a broadband is
to aggregate is to update edges because
most of the time we defined a nose first
and defined a the edges accordingly we
have the individuals first and we define
the relationship between the region
accordingly so the naps again is sunday
10th by the the attribute of itself at
previous time step as was its connecting
nose as well as the global attribute so
after we have all the edges updated you
have dated notice which is updated by
its neighboring edges as well as itself
and if I aggregate everything to the
master node which fall intern in the
next iteration influence all the nodes
and on the edges in your graph so if the
delete all cartoons and this is the the
pseudocode he will have so this is taken
out from the paper time google - member
and paper so there are a few things
worth mentioning here the first is that
all these for loops could either be
exact as in synchronous versus
asynchronous manner we chose to to
update them and aggregate them in a
synchronous manner simply the guest a is
fast and B you could very easily
preserved in various equal variance so
we put together a Kanab revel up in a
package that use graph nets to do
molecular machine learning particulate
so we have we rewrote the entire input
output path that by off a traditional
chemical kennel informatics toolkit so
that it could be integrated into
tensorflow
competition graph and executed in
parallel or put on GPU without any
dependencies so this time justice
not have an identities except as Urkel
2.0 the most the the most part the the
part that I'm most proud of in this
project is the design of this logo so
the first bit is both G the first time
every candidate or graph it is a
chemical graph if you are familiar with
chemistry rotated and you have a I
believe this is a probe in oxide or
versus something like that this is the
Camco graph and for those of you who are
not a comic gem it is a cocktail that's
a single mixture of gin lime juice and a
edge of lime served in a small cocktail
glass like this alright so just a few
words of how we implement it so we let a
user to feed in all the functions of
your choice so for example we have
update functions and all the aggregate
functions here and when you design your
own machinery Amazon you just put the
functions here and we have some default
functions which is sum or average or
attention some things like that that you
can use and after well this is one
example this is actually just the sound
function but because you need to deal
with the different dimensionalities
between your notes and your a global
attribute you need to do need to write
it a little bit differently this is how
to write a simple sum function here and
after this
we used the desert flow graph a
competition graph to compile everything
to a while loop and update that in a
time series so if you're interested in
this please go to our github repo and
this should point to you to a grouping
that we are putting together to about
the graph learning
Monaco space and from that I guess I'm
gonna and microphone to my colleague e
hiya
so talking about the applications
oh I'm sorry that's just another word
this is said this is a preliminary
result for that firm on business
learning and it's doing fine sorry do
you want to discuss this part for kinda
just good okay
all right so I'm going to talk about two
applications specifically her her know
in attribute and why it's important so
first for the application in our group
we run a lot of molecular models to make
chemical predictions and in these
simulations you can simulate proteins
now in order to set up these simulations
we need a we need many parameters and
one of the parameters we need is the
charge the partial charge of each now
why do we need a new way to create that
there are existing methods to predict
charges for the atoms however they're
either too expensive or if they're not
which is like using quantum mechanics or
if they are not expensive and empirical
there many times not very reliable so we
need a better way to predict it now so
we can what we can do is we can find the
partial charges on each atom by
minimizing the error between some
reference charge and the predicted
charge and this needs to be subject to a
constraint of the sum of all these
partial charges need to add up to the
total charge of the molecule now the
problem is that this total charge can be
either negative or positive or zero so
theoretically we can do this
optimization without the constraint and
then take the excess charge and spread
it evenly over the molecule and people
have done that however experimentally
when we tried it we weren't the ARMA C's
were just too high for it to be
acceptable so there's a different trick
that we can use
so in this case we take the potential
energy of the molecule that the charges
contribute and it has been shown that
the second-order Taylor expansion of
this potential energy is sufficient
approximation so we can define the first
order the first order derivative and a
second order derivative as II which is
electronegativity and s what gives a
heart so the electronegativity is the
tendency of an atom to pole and
preparedness to itself so the more
electron charges opposed to itself is
the more it will lower the potential
energies that's what's the first
derivative and in the second derivative
the hardness of the tendency of atoms to
bomb to each other so a molecule that's
harder will resist the tendency of
accumulating accumulating charges so we
defined ENS as the first and second
derivative and then we minimize Q as the
as the minimum as as the we we optimize
Q in terms of ENS so now we have this
optimization and turns out that there is
analytic solution using Lagrange
multipliers with the constraint of the
sum of the partial charges equal to the
total total charge of the molecule and
now this solution is something which is
down here that's the solution and this
is something that we can calculate the
end pretty in a pretty straightforward
way so we predict the end s and it's an
intermediate prediction and then we
optimize for the queues for the partial
charges this way and here what we're
showing is some of the results so here
we tested 350,000 molecules for Kendall
and what we're showing is on the on the
x-axis you have the reference charges
coming from quantum mechanics and the
predicted charges from our grassman and
we had an ARMA C which is around 0.02
which is pretty close to what the
artists see is from current you know
higher level of quantum mechanics
calculations and so the lower on semi
empirical methods now it's also
interesting to note is to see that so we
color-coded the data point with
different elements and this is showing
that they're all clustering together
which is showing of the graphs
Ned is learning something about the
chemical different chemical different
the different elements in the in the
molecule so now we're going to talk
about the per bond attributes which is
something called the partial charge I'm
sorry the partial bond water so why do
we need to predict the partial bond
water so it turns out there are several
levels of detail you can put into your
LEGO model so the high the more details
you have the more extensive this model D
and what I'm showing over here it's how
these different models grow with the
size of the system so in this case of
quantum mechanics
calculations which is already over here
we're ready you need an approximation of
this functional theory
grows by order n cubed and a semi
empirical quantum mechanics methods
grow an order of N and squared and the
molecular mechanics which is what we
usually run is order n log n so now the
problem is that chemical space is really
vast it is very very large and so what
that means is we need to somehow get a
handle on the space and find the
building blocks right so that we can
grow out larger and larger molecules the
problem is that it's not so simple to
just you know compare all these all
these find like similarities and then
find the building blocks that way
because electronic properties on
molecules non-local still changing one
far away from a lot and actually really
change the electronic properties so we
need a little bit of a more intelligent
way of fragmenting these molecules so it
turns out the partial bond order which
is a quantity that we can we can
calculate from semi empirical methods
gives us a very good idea of how the
alleged electrostatic potential or the
electron population overlap between bond
strengths when I drove the earth for
very similar molecules at all
benzene rings it's not sufficient and
the colors show a village but your Shack
potential and you see how it changes
with different substituents and then you
also see how the that motor also shifts
so on these shifts that which are
sometimes not very large trips but they
can really tell us a lot about the
chemical environment so we want to be
able to predict this value because it
tells us a lot about how different parts
of the molecule are changing it can help
us with figuring out where the fragment
molecules so now to generate a data set
that we can actually use to train this
we took a whole set of molecules from
FDA FDA approved drug like molecules and
we did a combinatorial fragmentation and
generate a whole bunch of fragments for
every molecule and then what we did was
we looked at the distribution of hybrid
bond waters for each for the for each
bond so let me take you through this one
example so this example I have koala
grasses and what would be at the red
bond so this is what the fighter-bomber
distribution looks like for this bond
and it so this is different in this
chemical environment now if you look at
all the fragments that have this bond
and we look at the distribution either
by the bond water what you find is that
they cluster and you vary and these vary
the same bins and when you look at the
fragments inside of these bins what we
I'm going to go through all the
chemistry here but what we find is that
there are actually really important
chemical differences that causes these
shifts so these is from you
tell us a lot about which parts of the
mouth you're not a couple to each other
so we didn't we thought we're gonna be
further along with a project when we
submitted the abstract so we haven't
actually so yes we actually haven't yet
trained on this data but our plan is to
train on this data so that we can find
the parts of the molecule that are
coupled to each other and this can get
this can give us a handle of finding the
you know the building blocks of chemical
space and the reason why we want those
bullets boxes now we can use higher
level of like hot more detail models to
predict different properties that is
then used for the for the less expensive
models that we can then you know build
up larger molecules so with that I would
like to thank everyone that had
contributed and we're open for questions
[Applause]
any questions
hey great presentation I'm wondering if
in your training data you only
considered covalent bonds between atoms
or you also considered
different proteins you start to have the
higher your quads that become really
important is that future word I'm sure
this is the bottle already
alright so well there are actually known
chemist that chemical bones
I can't go back on the abstraction
chemists have to represent the
structural molecules so Kuwait and bones
are more Venice or have a the
abstraction because they almost never
break
whereas hydrogen bonds could be regarded
as a result of some confirmations were
some specific structures off that
monocle so yes we could either mono mono
that has a bond with honor that's the
one or we can just neglect that bond and
hope that our model will recognize this
part in the structure that's what's
being tracked
who has a question any questions
[Music]
thank you so you mentioned but he's
beginning to talk you've mentioned among
the attributes free energy can you
explain how you're using free energy and
the we're training quite modest and I
wasn't explaining that very clearly so
what I think free energies it could mean
the whole wide range of things so it
could either be the form each energy or
something that is the attribute of the
molecule itself or alternatively we have
a fixed protein system we can also model
a dividing free energy of the molecule
with that protein in this way as long as
we're coating does not change so
sickening very fast they're different
things so if you want if you want to
model examples of quantum mechanics
attributes for example the formation of
free energy of molecules then it is only
a function of the spawning of the model
itself but it doesn't matter which laws
are looking at sy as you're looking at
this property it is only a function of
this ecology whereas if you are looking
at approaching the getting system things
are a bit different if you have one
protein you get from one model to to
expand the changing the body free energy
you have different coatings I'm afraid
that you would have to have like
multiple models as the transferability
of such models with protein against
system are still under very intensive
research and we don't have a clear
answer to that question yeah
I'm curious how stereoscopic senators
are getting any color to the model so
currently this model we're not including
it there are ways to encode it red using
[Music]
using words what yeah yeah and you know
even that way or you can use more like
sophisticated ways of what using
techniques also currently we're not
doing it
any more questions
if no question thanks for everybody
[Applause]